[наспівує мелодію]
[угорською]
Привіт!
Мене знімають.
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[заводить мотор та наспівує пісню «Я Дон Кіхот»]
[угорською]
Це мене знімають.
Ви знаєте, багато хто каже,
що Львів — столиця кави.
На Закарпатті лиш сміються.
У нас найсмачніша кава.
Це моя суб'єктивна думка.
[зітхає із задоволенням]
[угорською]
Доброго дня.
Можеш угорською?
[угорською]
Мені, будь ласка, два капучіно.
Один з корицею, а інший — з підсолоджувачем,
[угорською]
можеш і шоколад насипати.
Дякую.
[Берегове,
Закарпаття]
Оскільки ми — угорський театр,
ми граємо виключно угорською мовою.
Наш театр унікальний тому,
що ми самі були і робітниками сцени,
і виготовляли дещо.
Тобто ми дійсно жили театром.
За національністю я угорець.
Це моя рідна мова.
[Андрій Качур
Директор угорського театру в Берегові]
Тільки коли я потрапив в Київ,
я зрозумів, що українська мова чудова.
Стараюся розмовляти нею по можливості.
Але вдома з дружиною й дітьми
спілкуємося угорською.
Цукор.
Одну ложку додай.
Добре.
— Щоб на двох.
— Один?
Мало пішло?
Сип ще.
Ти нікуди не йдеш?
[угорською]
Зачекай, ти на першу йдеш?
Пообідайте, добре? Зігрійте собі їсти.
[угорською]
Бувайте.
Все, бувайте.
Угорці тут живуть
протягом восьмисот років.
Та ну, більше!
Місту Берегове 940 чи 960 років.
— Тисяча шістсот...
— 996 років.
996 років. У мене з математикою недобре.
Знаю, що 1063 року засноване місто.
Це була територія Королівства Угорщина.
— [угорською] Привіт всім.
[угорською]
Привіт, дівчата і хлопці.
Привіт.
Я вперше почула літературну українську
мову в Києві, на сцені.
[Іболя Орос
Акторка]
До того я в Ужгороді чула тільки по-закарпатськи.
Як тут говорять...
Це є така мова...
Своєрідний діалект такий.
Там, коли я почула, я [думаю]:
«Боже мій, це і є українська мова?
Яка ж вона гарна!»
Я ніколи не могла собі уявити,
що я в Ужгороді не те чую,
що це не справжня українська.
Коли народився старший син, ми просто
домовилися, що дитині так легше буде вчити:
[Олег Мельничук
Режисер, актор]
один з батьків говорить своєю рідною мовою,
інший — своєю.
Так сталося,
що я угорка, а він українець —
і ми не хотіли позбавити їх
можливості говорити двома рідними мовами.
[Велика Бийгань,
Закарпаття]
[угорською] Ходи, ходи. Йди сюди.
Оскільки я військовий, я не звик
ховатися на горищі чи десь іще.
Пішов я в військкомат.
[Бейло Лешко
Військовий]
Спитав: «Я вам потрібен?»
«Звісно, ви нам потрібні».
Так я і пішов в АТО.
Я етнічний угорець.
Живу в Україні.
Не маю права відсторонитися від всього цього.
Ну і провокації, як і всюди на той час, були.
«Навіщо ви сюди прийшли наших вбивати?»
і подібне.
«Йдіть звідси», — це було спочатку.
Коли ми мали їхати звідти,
до нас прийшли люди і кажуть:
«Хлопці, не їдьте.
Відтоді як ви тут, у нас порядок є».
До речі, це дика черешня.
Якою великою буває!
І дика черешня може бути великою.
Поїхали в Селидове з патрулем.
Все як годиться, з бронежилетом,
каскою, автоматом.
В Селидовому ми зупинилися
біля продуктового магазину.
В машині водій, теж наш — угорець.
За звичкою говорю до нього угорською.
Бачу морозиво і кажу:
«Жовтий, ходи туди. Будеш морозиво?»
Кажу: [угорською] «Буду-буду».
Продавчиня підійшла, подивилася і питає:
«Ви що, НАТОвці?»
[сміється]
Так.
Люди там (на сході України) взагалі не знали,
що в Україні живуть угорці.
«А як ви з Угорщини сюди потрапили?»
«Ми живемо на Закарпатті».
«А що, на Закарпатті є угорці?»
Угорці сюди не переїжджали.
Вони тут народилися, просто кордони змінилися.
Моя бабуся жила в чотирьох країнах,
не виїжджаючи зі свого села.
Їй і не потрібно було. Просто кордони...
Змінювали.
Є конкретна історія.
В Ужгородському районі є село (Малі Селменці), навпіл поділене кордоном.
Одна половина села залишилася в Словаччині,
інша — в Україні.
І там, і там живуть угорці.
Родини роз'єдналися.
П'єсу писали про це село,
але й водночас про усіх нас.
Відновлюються будинки культури
в угорських селах,
де на 99% мешканців —
це угорська етнічна меншина.
Навпаки, мені здається, більше йде
стимуляція того, щоб люди залишатися тут —
угорці не виїжджали до Угорщини.
А саме залишалися тут і працювали.
— Коли говоритиму?
— Так-так-так!
А як я тоді підійду?
Може, не треба верхні дверцята відкривати,
а лише ці?
Все одно звідти дістаю взуття.
— Ага.
— І шарф.
І контровий є, і профіль нормальний.
Не встиг. Що ти вигадуєш?
Добре, все.
— Наскільки я знаю моїх нащадків...
— Предків.
Предків.
[сміється]
Нікого не було з іншої нації.
Тому я ніколи й уявити собі не могла, що..
[сміється] Слов'янина вибереш?
Так, що так судилося.
У 1998 році ми познайомилися.
Іболя тоді була ще студенткою
четвертого курсу акторського.
— Вже закінчувала тоді.
— Якраз так.
Якраз закінчувала.
А я приїхав працювати до Києва — тобто повернувся
в той самий театральний гуртожиток.
— От і там познайомилися.
— Став моїм сусідом.
Став сусідом. У сусідніх кімнатах.
А потім усе, вона закінчила [університет]
і поїхала сюди працювати.
Довго не витримав.
Поїхав за своїм скарбом. [захоплено]
Так.
Поміняв перед цим три театри.
В кожному рік-два [попрацював],
а тут уже на двадцять років застряг.
[угорською]
Ходи, ходи, ходи.
Стоп. Добре.
Ні, тоді через інше плече.
[мугикає з роздратуванням у голосі]
Отак розвертайся, ага.
Перехоплюй, бери шарфик.
І йди по ньому.
Для мене театр — це найголовніше.
Це важливіше за все.
То або володіє тобою, або...
Тобі нема чого робити в мистецтві.
Я собі сказав,
що це найкращий театр для мене.
З усіх, які я бачив.
В Україні, може, про нього хтось і не знає...
Хтось знає. А в Європі знають добряче.
Потужні фестивалі і гарні відгуки,
перемоги на тих фестивалях.
Фестиваль «Контакт» в Польщі, в Торуні.
Три роки тому наш театр був
з України єдиний, який потрапив
в Париж на фестиваль.
Коли запрошують, то, звичайно...
добре, але ми ж маємо і вдома зіграти.
Глядачі чекають.
Моя головна ціль —
займатися театром тут, на Закарпатті.
Погода цього року дуже завадила.
Минулого року в цю пору
у мене огірки майже свої були вже.
А зараз вони ще досі в ящиках.
Мій батько був директором
сільського будинку культури.
Я завжди був поміж тих музикантів, танцівників.
Був театр самодіяльності — я завжди там крутився.
У мене було цікаве життя.
Чого мене навчав батько?
«Передусім, передусім, синку,
це інтереси країни, де ти живеш.
А потім твоє, особисте.
Якщо в країні все буде добре,
то й у тебе теж усе буде добре».
Я локал-патріот.
Звісно, я люблю Угорщину
як історичну Батьківщину,
але я люблю Закарпаття, розумієте?
Найкраще місто для мене — Берегове.
Краще не буває.
Тут мене кожне дерево знає, кожен стовп.
Кожен сусід вітається.
Закарпаття завжди було багатонаціональним.
Коли, скажімо, євреї святкують щось,
щонайменше я тихіше
поводитимуся поряд з ними
і дам їм посвяткувати.
Коли я святкую, то
якось чекаєш того, все, дайте спокій
на пів дня чи на день  — у мене свято.
Це працює не те, щоб роками,
а десятками років, якщо не більше.
У нас на Закарпатті два Різдва.
Два або навіть і три Нових роки.
Святкуємо двічі Великдень.
Двічі — Святу Трійцю.
Нема проблем.
Довго це не було проблемою, лиш поки син
не подорослішав і не задумався:
«Мама, а що Ісус двічі народився?»
[сміється]
Ми тоді навіть не знали, що відповісти.
Ще маленький був і не розумів,
що щось тут не так.
Миколай два рази приходить:
5 грудня і 19 грудня.
Це завжди було так.
Я, мабуть, заражена цим повітрям.
Я вчилася в Будапешті, в Києві,
але ані там, ані там не хотілося б постійно жити.
Це відчуття і залишається.
Неважливо де: в Ужгороді чи у Береговому.
Щораз, коли перетинаю кордон, повертаючись
в Україну, є відчуття, що ось, це моє.
Я народився тут.
Золото під ногами.
Куди ще йти? Де би було краще?
Тут поряд зі мною мої друзі.
У мене тут є моя справа.
Куди їхати і для чого?
Було б легше?
Не думаю.
А щастя і тут є.
Щастя не шукати треба,
а взяти за руку і тримати.
От і все.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Макс Салій (Завалля), Сергій Розов]
[Субтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[USAID
Серія створена за підтримки
Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]